welcome back to las vegas now you can't
celebrate mexican independence day
without mexican food okay zephyr's cafe
inside the sahara is making sure we are
full of mexican pride and food on friday
september 16th chef alicia chevitone
star of cincinnati kitchen is here to
tell us how we're doing it how are you
i'm doing great rocky thanks so much for
having me oh please thank you for
gracing us with your food okay so this
is your very first pop of dinner this is
my first pop-up on the strip
yes this is my first pop-up on the strip
so i'm very very excited to be
explaining uh having that uh at sahara
las vegas it's a really phenomenal
opportunity and we've got a six-course
dinner that we're preparing for mexican
independence day this friday the 16th at
six o'clock and we're having mexican
inspired cuisine of course
and also tequila pairings yeah you can't
afford the food without
the drinks but let's get into your into
the dish you're making for us because
this is just one item on the on the
curated yes yes i've actually brought
two to show you today so we have our ahi
tostada which is made with hawaiian big
eye tuna that's flown in fresh it's
sashimi style
very very interesting spin on a
traditional mexican dish we also have
our shrimp ceviche verde which i'm going
to assemble for you today okay
so basically this is peeled and deveined
shrimp okay and we marinate that right
with this beautiful
this beautiful marinade which is made
from serrano pepper okay garlic lime
juice
salt and pepper we've got a bunch of
great uh flavors in here and we
essentially too it is so simple you just
kind of wear it in a blender right right
and what happens is essentially the lime
juice activates
the shrimp so you refrigerate this for
it is chemistry it's a chemical reaction
that happens
uh refrigerate this for about an hour
and then it's good to go we mix in some
very fresh avocado plate it with some
nice cilantro and there you go that's
your shrimp ceviche verde delicious
delicious now just name a few other
items that will be on the menu as well
yeah so we actually have a crispy pork
belly which is chicharron
we also have iberia dish so birya is
stewed beef in this case originally uh
authentic as goat but we're serving it
with beef
and it's sort of a nod to jalisco which
is where tequila is produced so we
thought that would be an interesting
spin uh and you're going to end the
evening with the chocolate tamales so
you are not going to leave here hungry
this sounds amazing now tell everybody
how they can
get tickets to your pop-up dinner they
can get tickets on eventbrite so you can
either chef chef alicia search or also
search on sahara las vegas and it's yes
it's our mexican inspired dinner at
sahara las vegas pop-up six o'clock on
eventbrite thank you chef alicia